wages one of the problems right now
obviously is that a lot of people aren't
going back to work there's tons of open
roles not a lot of people want to go
fill the roles so what ends up happening
is that companies
in a tight labor market have to begin to
raise
what they're willing to pay people and
they have to raise
the perks that they give those people as
an incentive to get them to come
and work it's pretty simple when you
start to understand how the world works
around incentives
everything becomes obvious so i want
people to come and work here i've
opened jobs people don't want to come
work here so what do i do oh maybe i'll
pay a little bit more money maybe i'll
offer some more perks
the problem is that as they're doing
that
the people who already work at the
companies are saying wait a minute hey
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
you pay me 15 bucks an hour and you're
gonna offer that person 17
an hour why don't i get paid 17 an hour
how come you won't
increase my compensation why don't i get
those perks
so there's a balance if you jack up what
you're willing to pay or you jack up the
perks for the new roles
your existing employees then become
upset and so this
has created a very unique position for a
lot of companies we're seeing
all sorts of uh complexity companies are
raising prices
because what they're doing is as they
have to increase what they're paying to
their existing employees or to new
employees
they pass that cost on to the end
consumer so they raise their prices
we have from the ally finance
chief human resources officer everyone
talks about their pay now
the new generation is very open about it
so making sure you have fairness and are
able to justify and explain that is
extremely
important kathy patterson i grew up
and when i first started working it was
like taboo you weren't allowed to talk
about what you got paid that was that
was a no-no and if they heard that you
were talking about what you got paid
you was in trouble but what now ally is
saying is that young people this is
exactly what they're doing
does that cause problems for the
employer probably i believe so
yeah i mean it puts them in an awkward
stamp uh situation but you also got to
remember like if you're offering
uh and you're publicly saying hey look
like chipotle we're going to give all of
our employees 15
minimum wages when when they come in
we're going to pass along with customers
not necessarily chipotle is the best
example but companies that raise
uh the the wages for kind of entry level
employees and all these things
the people that already work there
consistently and have these jobs at even
higher positions are going to want
raises also right if you're saying hey
look we're raising this combat inflation
hire people the unemployment market
is really bad right now uh we need to
pay these people more money the people
that hold the higher positions are going
to want raises too right
and those are things that cannot be
taken back so once you give that raise
and once you say hey look we're paying
15
an hour for entry level you can't go
down so i think what we're seeing is a
lot of these companies uh the companies
that need to hire are doing it because
they don't really have a choice
but the companies that can wait uh 6 12
18 months potentially
and hold off and say hey look maybe this
calms down maybe it cools off in the
next
year year and a half and we could hire
back at the consistent rates that we
were used to
without offering all these perks and all
these incentives that's what we're gonna
do because we know once we do it we
can't come back from it if
employees are all talking about their
pay does that hold the company
in a position where they have to be
accountable and they have to create a
fair system
well what do you mean like the more
transparency if i know what you're
getting paid and you're getting paid and
you know what i'm getting paid
then the company is more incentivized to
make sure that they're paying us all
adequately
yeah for sure if everyone is public
about it and knows uh yeah i think it
incentivizes them to make sure that
they're doing it in the correct way
i was talking to somebody on the phone
today and he said that he once had a
situation where
uh he hired somebody they came in they
were like in an apprentice role this is
a manufacturing business this is a great
story he said that the
apprentice said hey when can i get paid
as much as that guy
and that guy was the head of the
manufacturing floor
right and the guy who was an apprentice
is an impressive guy he had a military
background all this stuff
and and so they were saying that um you
know it's like he was like any dummy
and so the response from the business
owner was the following when do you
think that you can do
what he can do yeah and the guy's like i
don't know like maybe 10 years i don't
know maybe never and he goes well that's
when you'll get paid like him
is when you can do his job then you'll
get paid like his job right
that's how it works and so i do think
that there's an element of
you you constantly if people know hey
john's getting paid
you know x dollars and i'm getting paid
x minus 20
oh i i i'm better than john i should get
paid what john gets paid right so there
is an element of that but it also forces
the companies to be much more
uh kind of fair in what they did yeah
and i think it's tough because if you
just say hey look this
this job you're always going to have
some kind of conflict right of people
that think they're not being treated
fairly
and that's always uh one of the
difficult things to kind of expel out of
an organization i think because
if you say hey look we're going to pay
all of uh kind of this entry level roll
this
we're going to pay kind of the next step
up this and the step up above that this
there's always gonna be people that are
not only uh thinking that they should be
on that level
but people within those levels that
think that they do better quality work
than someone else
so it's tough uh it's it's i think it's
helpful to be transparent in some cases
uh but i also think it makes it more
challenging people who switched
jobs from june 2020 to june 2021
saw on average basically a six percent
raise
people who stayed in the same job saw
three percent increase there's a rule of
thumb
uh dad told me this one time our dad uh
he said
yeah you know what they say i don't know
what they say and he said if you work
somewhere for two years you're getting
underpaid after that
that's probably a pretty good rule right
because once you get in it's not like
they're gonna double your salary right
they're basically going to give you kind
of increases maybe get a promotion a
little bit extra cash
but you definitely fall behind where if
you constantly go into the free market
and getting repriced
then you probably would accelerate your
income faster that way so you see a lot
of kids like directly at a school right
their their first entry level job
may not even be necessarily the company
they want to work for but the industry
they want to be in
uh is a lot more important and the
skills that they learn are very
important so they know that hey i might
leave in a year might leave in two years
or whatever and just kind of use this
name recognition as a way to like up
myself and up my salary and up my job
um one thing that you were talking about
was in seattle
at t-mobile park there's a lady there
that made
16.70 an hour and she during the
pandemic they hired a bunch of new
people and the city increased the
minimum wage to 1669.
uh so she was making a penny more than
people that she was training even though
she's worked there for years
right and it is crazy it has since been
renegotiated but at one point in time
she's making a penny more
than people per hour per hour than
people she's training
she she's the one giving them yeah but
that's where it comes down to right if
you're gonna offer higher wages for
uh you're gonna raise wages to
incentivize people to come and work for
you
you're to have to do the same thing on
higher level jobs and you just mentioned
it it's not happening on an equal basis
right the the new employees are getting
a six percent raise year over year and
existing employees that already work in
these organizations are getting a three
percent ratio every year so we can
already see that uh they're getting
they're getting mispriced essentially
right
but it's because these organizations
know if we give them these raises
you can't come back from them so even if
the job market cools off in you know
uh 6 12 18 months whatever it is we're
going to have to pay these wages so
maybe we can wait it out maybe we can't
but if we give them this raise we're
gonna have to consistently give that to
them every single quarter every single
week every single month
all right these two charts first the
longest period in history without an
increase in the federal minimum wage has
we are living in right now today the
federal minimum wage
is worth 17 less than 10 years ago
and 31 percent less than in 1968
what this means is that in july of 2009
there was a minimum wage of dollars and
twenty five
cents that seven dollars and twenty five
cents
in today's terms would be the equivalent
of eight dollars and seventy cents
so what this chart is showing is that if
you have been getting paid
minimum wage since july of 2009
you are getting paid less today more
than a dollar less
in purchasing power terms today than you
were
then now that's only up until 2019. that
doesn't include the trillions of dollars
that were printed recently
so the odds are that you have lost
two dollars or more in purchasing power
per hour since
2009 which means that even though they
told you we're paying you seven dollars
and 25 cents and we pay that every
single hour for years and years and
years and years
you're actually getting paid less in
purchasing power it feels like
everything around you is becoming
more and more expensive this is why
it is essential in today's economy
that you have investments i don't care
what you invest in
do your own research make sure you're
educated but you cannot
sit there get paid an hourly wage that
stays the same whether it's 7.25
10 15 or 20 it does not matter
you have to continue every year to get
an increase in your hourly rate
and then the money that you save after
you pay your expenses every month
has to some portion of it go into
investments because that is the only way
that you are going to continue to
preserve and increase your purchasing
power over time
if you do not do that every single thing
in your world is going to get more
expensive and you're going to still
end up in a worse and worse position the
feeling that you can't get ahead
that you're on that rat wheel you're
just running
on the little hamster wheel rat wheel
whatever they call it
wheel yeah hamster wheel rat wheel
whatever you're just running on it you
can't get off
it's because your pay isn't going up and
you're also not invested
that to me is the craziest chart that we
might have ever pulled up on this show
is that literally in today's terms the
minimum wage
used to be eight dollars and seventy
cents but now with
uh the the uh devaluation of the
currency it's seven dollars and twenty
five so not
john just read the stat it was in uh
experience workers over the last year
their pay's only up three percent right
so inflation the government's even
saying it's higher than that and we know
that they undershoot it usually so think
if it's two or three times that that's
really bad
back to what you were saying anthony um
did you just call me anthony
yeah no no no no no in 1973
the minimum wage was around four dollars
equivalent the pershing power would have
to be 25
over three times the minimum wage today
they would have had to
increase it three times to keep the same
exact purchasing power since then yeah
that's not can you imagine if people
right now we're talking about 25 minimum
wage
companies would be like dude people are
struggling everyone's bragging about 15
yeah
companies would literally fire every
employee
they would have i mean think about that
if they actually had to pay
a wage that was equivalent to what it
used to be
this absolutely would cause mass layoffs
because companies just couldn't afford
it like imagine every restaurant every
restaurant having to say okay now every
single person that works you have to pay
25
an hour or more it's just they wouldn't
be able to operate their businesses
right
so it's a very very bad situation but
you as an individual you're in control
you can make changes you can get out of
this situation
hey guys thanks so much for watching
that clip of the best business show make
sure you like and subscribe to the
channel turn on notifications so you
know when we go live every weekday and
then head to sofi.com
so that you can get an account we can
get after it